mesdames messieurs bon dimanche en quête
d'un levier pour contrôler l'inflation
la Banque du Canada a augmenté son taux
directeur la semaine dernière pour une
sixième fois en moins d'un an à la
hausse des prix à la consommation
s'ajoute dorénavant des taux d'emprunt
de plus en plus élevé le mot récession
est maintenant évoqué régulièrement
malgré tout le ministre des Finances du
Québec affirme qu'il en aura les
promesses électorales de son parti a
commencé par un versement unique de 400
à 600 dollars avant Noël pour plus de 6
millions de Québécois
Eric Girard admet tout de même que le
ralentissement de l'économie va imposer
aux mini budget qu'il déposera en
décembre une série de choix pour mieux
contrôler les dépenses à quoi les
Québécois doivent-ils s'attendre j'ai
posé la question au ministre Girard que
j'ai rencontré dans ses bureaux de
Montréal
[Musique]
Eric Gérard bonjour merci d'être avec
nous c'est un plaisir c'est Gérard vous
êtes de nouveau ministre des Finances
vous avez été recondu dans le poste
dites moi de quoi aller à l'économie
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qu'elle
était durant votre premier mandat
c'est pas si beaucoup de choses dans le
premier mandat on a eu avec la pandémie
la pire récession depuis la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale ça a eu un impact sur
les finances publiques on a eu un
déficit de 10 millions de dollars
l'année 2021 ensuite il y a eu un rebond
synchronisé de l'économie mondiale et
c'est un des principaux facteurs
derrière la hausse de l'inflation c'est
que tout le monde a rebondi en même
temps et la demande était concentrée sur
les biens parce que les services étaient
contraints par les règles Center ça crée
de l'inflation la semaine dernière la
Banque du Canada TEF ma crème le
gouverneur de la banque a aussi de
nouveau le taux d'escompte d'un demi
point on est à 3,75 3,75 puis a dit on
revient pas à la normale encore avant
2024 sa place le Québec dans lequel ça
vous place vous dans quel contexte alors
que vous êtes sur le point déposé une
mise à jour économique mais d'abord faut
voir que c'est une hausse de parce qu'il
va probablement avoir un autre 25 points
de base en décembre on va atteindre 4%.
alors on va être essentiellement passer
de autour de 0% à 4% en 6 mois c'est
sans précédent au niveau de la vitesse
ça ralentit la demande des ménages ça
ralentit les décisions d'investissement
des entreprises d'embauche tous les
économie ralentis
et donc c'est moins croissance
pour nous 1% PIB nominal c'est à peu
près 1 milliard par année de revenus et
dans le fosse que la Banque du Canada
nous a dit c'est que la croissance au
Canada en 2023 va être inférieur à 1%
puis ça va être la même chose au Québec
vous venez de faire campagne en faisant
des promesses avec avec des prévisions
financières qui étaient plus optimistes
que ce qui est en train de se dessiner
devant vous quel impact ça a sur
certaines des promesses phares que vous
avez mis de la campagne mais d'abord le
code financier il était prudent il
contenait des provisions le rapport
électoral il y avait deux milliards de
provisions par année pour les imprévus
soit pandémiques soit économique alors
on avait prévu les coûts de reconditions
programme on avait prévu l'effet de
l'inflation sur les infrastructures sur
les dépenses opérations alors on avait
un code financier prudent c'est certain
que on a des promesses fiscales
importantes et nécessairement on se
trouve à redonner au québecois leur
argent parce que nos revenus ont
augmenté avec l'inflation et là on
redonne de l'argent vont aller à la
baisse les revenus vont aller à la
baisse mais encore une fois on n'est pas
il n'y a aucune certitude qui aura une
récession vous vous y croyez vous
secteur privé disent c'est à peu près
impossible qu'on se ramasse pas en
récession un nom il y a autant de
prévisions qui a d'économistes la
probabilité qu'il y succession c'est
approximativement 50%, d'autant plus
qu'on va avoisiner 0% de croissance sur
une période de 12 mois alors on sera
peut-être au dessus peut-être en bas
vous avez annoncé des trucs en campagne
électorale il y avait des éléments
importants des grosses dépenses
commençons par le chèque que vous avez
promis au Québécois avant Noël 400 600
dollars je sais que monsieur Legault a
dit c'est toujours là il y a pas
question de revenir là-dessus qu'est-ce
que vous êtes à ceux qui disent que ce
genre de mesure là ça alimente la
poussée inflationniste mais les gens qui
disent ça il y a un problème de mesure
dans cette affirmation là parce que
l'économie du Québec c'est 550 milliards
de PIB nominal puis là on parle d'une
mesure de trois points 5 milliards donc
c'est moins que 1% du PIB alors de dire
que c'est inflationniste funéraire
d'intuition économique les gens qui
voudraient
il y a quatre points 6 millions de
personnes qui gagnent moins de 50000
dollars qui vont recevoir 600 dollars
ces gens-là en ont besoin pour
l'alimentation le transport les
vêtements le logement ce sont des
besoins
logiciel ces gens-là on a besoin donc on
donne à 6.4 millions de personnes dont
4.6 millions gagnent moins de 50 000
c'est une excellente vous êtes engagé
aussi à réduire de 1% les deux premiers
paliers d'imposition tu as 2023 ça tient
toujours oui mais on parle d'un
ralentissement économique et qu'est-ce
que vient de faire un stimuli fiscal
quel est le meilleur moment pour amener
un stimuli fiscal lorsque c'est lorsque
l'économie ralentit monsieur Legault a
parlé la semaine dernière de dans le
contexte actuel vous alliez de devoir
faire des choix oui qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire faire des choix vous faites
des choix deux éléments dont on vient de
parler vous avez pas l'intention toucher
à ça non c'est quoi faire des choix mais
par exemple au niveau du Plan québécois
d'infrastructure on est déjà à 142
milliards sur 10 ans et ça c'est
approximativement toute proportion
gardée une fois et demie la taille du
Plan québécois d'infrastructure de
l'Ontario nous sommes une fois demi la
taille du plan de l'Ontario donc on a
des besoins d'infrastructure on veut
rénover l'ensemble de nos écoles
on veut ajouter des infrastructures
sportives il y a des logements sociaux
il y a des il y a des besoins importants
mais on a des contraintes de capacité
financière on a aussi des contraintes
physiques de travailleurs de films
d'ingénierie alors on atteint on
approche de la limite de la taille du
Plan québécois d'infrastructure à 142
milliards et donc faut faire des choix
alors dans ce que vous dites vous êtes
en train de dire à des parents qui
attendaient de voir leur école de
quartier rénovée ou à des gens qui ont
besoin d'une infrastructure des villes
qui ont besoin d'une infrastructure
maintenant parce que les vieillissantes
vous allez peut-être devoir attendre
mais je vous dirais que pour les écoles
ça a été dit en campagne littéral que
c'était une priorité de rénover les
écoles oui alors peut-être qu'il y aura
plus de rénovation d'école puis un peu
moins de les écoles par exemple je
laisse cette responsabilité là de faire
ces choix là au nouveau ministre
responsable des infrastructures mais
c'est un exemple où il faudra faire des
choix un mot sur un autre responsabilité
qu'on vous a confié dans le remaniement
ministériel vous êtes
responsable des relations avec la
communauté anglophone pour pourquoi on
vous a convié ça je pense que on veut
améliorer les relations c'est un message
positif du moins je l'espère
d'intlusion d'ouverture il y a un
million de Québécois qui dont la langue
première et l'anglais approximativement
13% de la population on va amener le
Québec à une autre niveau amélioré tout
ça la communauté anglophone fait partie
de ça on a besoin de la contribution de
tous les Québécois alors mon rôle c'est
vraiment de comprendre les irritants il
y en a on n'est pas naïf et de voir si
on peut faire des gestes
pour améliorer les relations et que tous
se sentent inclus dans notre projet
ces relations là par votre gouvernement
nous ce qu'on a voulu on a fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour
la promotion du français
la protection du français et ça c'est
notre première responsabilité mais
d'aucune façon et le Premier ministre le
dit d'aucune façon la promotion la
protection du français ne doit nuire ou
neuwera à la qualité des services ou au
droit de la communauté anglophone
Eric Gérard merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup